Hi, this is Michelle Hamburger with Connors Clinic,
and I am fortunate enough to be able to interview again,
Jim Crommer of EMF inspecting Jim and his wife,
LaRaye, own an EMF inspection company
where they can go into home and businesses
and help them learn how to remediate or remove
some of the harmful EMFs that are doing so much damage
in our society right now.
So thank you so much for being with me today, Jim.
Well, thank you, Michelle,
and I would just like to say that I feel like
I'm the one who's fortunate on your program
and just really appreciate it,
and I'm excited for the opportunity to share with people
how they might be helped and protected
from the blasting of EMFs that we're getting all around us.
Oh, well, this is my absolute pleasure.
So let's jump in.
And today, we're going to talk about home EMFs,
and one of the things I want to mention before we begin
is that Jim is being gracious enough to offer up
things that we can do on our own
to help our homes stay healthier,
and things that we need to be watching out for
as far as the major culprits he's going to be addressing
three specific culprits that are in our homes
that seem to emit the greatest amount of EMFs,
but that's not also to take away from the importance
of having somebody who isn't expert
and is aware of what's going on in this field
to come in or to provide counsel on what you can do.
So we're going to be getting you started,
but know that this rabbit hole goes very, very deep.
And so I'm just so grateful that Jim is willing
to disseminate some of this information
to begin to get people on their way,
but know that on the end of this video,
we will have information to Jim and Lorace Company
so that if you would like further help in this,
you can reach out to them.
So Jim, go ahead and take it away and get us started.
Okay, Michelle.
And the rabbit hole is getting deeper.
Yes.
You know, with the, with the advent of 5G,
and with the internet of things,
it's like they want to make smart everything.
And so people, yeah, we're just,
we just hope more and more become aware
and take steps because it's very,
it's very harmful, very dangerous.
And we're talking serious diseases.
And so I know you're concerned about that too.
And so, but anyway, let's take the first one then.
And this is actually the strongest EMF radiating device
that people have in their home.
And it's called a microwave oven.
So microwave ovens use EMFs to heat their food,
your food, and they use 2.45 gigahertz RF radiation.
So these are microwave energy,
and it passes through the cells and molecules of the food.
And it makes the molecules vibrate millions of times per second.
And that's the friction that generates heat
to heat up your food.
So that, that sounds wonderful, doesn't it?
I mean, it's fast, it's easy.
I mean, probably when you go into most restaurants,
they're doing that and people have these,
most people have them at their home.
I mean, they're just built right in.
But here's the problem, they all leak radiation.
All of them, it doesn't matter if they're new,
it doesn't matter if they're old.
We've tested them, and they all leak radiation.
And furthermore, the government guidelines,
which would supposedly protect people is so high,
I'll just give you an idea.
The government regulations like 10 million microwaves,
safe level is 100.
So I mean, come on.
So basically, it's frying you and your food.
But there isn't, and also this too,
the signal that sends out is very strong.
And so it goes right through the walls,
right through the ceilings, right through the people,
right through everything, and it's nasty too.
So we have really cool meters that make noise.
And this is good too, because sometimes,
you know, maybe the husband's into it,
and the wife is in her vice versa.
And so we go over, and they hear that, and they go,
whoa, what's that?
Because like I said, it's indiscible.
But when you hear it, then you go,
that's for real.
And the microwave has this really weird sound coming from it.
And it's just, and your body's feeling it.
Your cells are feeling it, they're getting zapped,
and they're feeling it, even if you can't experience yourself.
But there are many people now who are getting,
what's called EHS, which is electric hypersensitivity,
and they are feeling it, and they can tell,
and then it's really, it's even debilitating for them.
So.
Well, and if you think of what microwave radiation
is doing to your body, or as a potential to do to your body,
think of what it's also doing to your food,
and then you're consuming that as nutrition.
And hoping that that's going to feed your body.
So I know that I've heard of studies
where people have microwave water.
I think there was actually an elementary school boy.
And I'm not going to remember the reference of the study
where he had microwave water and he'd
watered one plant with microwave water
and another plant with just traditional water.
And the microwave water ended up damaging
or killing the actual plant.
Yes.
Yeah, and you're just wondering what I was going into,
but the, yeah, and I've seen those on YouTube.
The, it's not totally scientific, but it sure is interesting.
Like I'm killing the plant there.
So, but there are many studies that show microwaves
destroy the nutrients in your food.
There was one by the Journal of Science
that showed broccoli cooked in a microwave
lost almost all of its antioxidants.
Broccoli is good, good deal, especially if you get organic.
But there it goes.
There goes your nutrition.
And then some Russian and Japanese studies have discovered
that foods lose 16 and 90% of their food value
when cooked in microwave ovens.
So yeah, so, okay.
So it's destroying, destroying your nutrients,
but then even worse, it's causing free radicals.
And those attack the cells of our body and damage them.
And it's one of the main causes of cancer
when I had normal growth of cells because they're damaged.
So, yeah, so it's not just, well, microwave,
maybe it's happened to me some, no, no,
it's just two and more than that.
And so, yeah, yeah, it's a bad deal.
Are there certain microwaves on the market
that emit less radiation than others?
Are there anything that would be a good modification
or in reality is every single microwave
doing the same amount of damage to people and to food?
Well, it is, I'm sure the levels vary,
but I'd say they're all just so, so high.
It's not, it's not good.
No, I do not know of anything.
And I don't think the microwave oven companies care.
They just want to sell them.
So yeah, but it's, I think as I was studying,
they have come out and almost,
I think almost everybody has one,
is some are getting wise and getting rid of them.
I was at one home and I said, here,
I'll just test it for you.
And then a little while later, she goes,
will you help me?
Will you help me?
And I said, sure, she said, I'm gonna carry this,
she wanted me to carry the microwave
with her down into the basement to get rid of it.
She says my husband can't carry it, he's not strong.
But so, so that, what you wanted,
but I mean, it's for real.
Now, there's also something that people should know about too.
And that's when plastics are microwaved.
And when they are microwaved, dangerous chemicals
like BPA can leak out of the containers,
the covers or the wrap, and it's absorbed into the food.
And these chemicals really mess with your body's hormones.
And I know Michelle, you know all this.
And again, a bad risk of developing problems,
fertility, cancer, and on and on and on.
So it's a, yeah, it's a big deal and people are unaware
and they'll actually make some coffee or something
and they'll just stand in front of it.
Look, how's it doing in there?
It wants to know.
Because it's closer you are.
But more you're getting zapped.
The stronger the signal.
Right.
So what would be probably the wisest thing if a family was open
to getting rid of their microwave,
what are some things that families can do to remove it,
but then to also have an element of convenience
still in the home of the simplicity of not having
to fire up the full stove.
Right.
And first of all, on our safety tips here,
safety tips here.
If you don't have one, don't buy one.
Try to be a no-brainer.
And if you have one, don't use it.
And if you like it because it fits nice
above the stove top, or you know,
it fits in your aesthetics of your home,
unplug it also.
Because even when it's not on,
there's still like fields around it that we've tested.
Electric fields and even magnetic fields rating,
not not as far as the regular microwave,
but they're still radiating off.
And if you're cooking on the stove,
that could be right by your head too.
So any rate, but yeah, so what do you do?
I actually will use the microwave for one thing.
And that's to heat up my heating pad with the beads in it.
But I get out of the room when I do it.
But I think maybe the best would be like a convection oven.
What about a toaster oven?
Some things are more?
Okay, yeah.
Absolutely.
And then really, I mean,
are we gonna sacrifice our health
on the ultra convenience?
And some people are, you know, I mean, seriously.
I think there are people in the world
who even if you could absolutely prove
which we can, that EMFs are dangerous,
they're not doing anything.
Just because they like their cell phone next to their head,
they like, you know, all their conveniences
and they'll just do it.
But for those who will have ears to hear, you know,
listen up and take precautions because this is not only
like if you're on your deathbed or serious diseases,
this is prevention.
Just like you would eat healthy, you would exercise,
you know, you would take your nutritionals.
This is prevention and prevention is better
than trying to get cured and healed.
Agreed.
You would not believe how much we see that in our clinic
and that is our biggest struggle is to divorce
our patients from their current conveniences
and current lifestyle that has led them
to a point of developing dishears.
So you are completely right about that.
That makes sense, you know, and right.
And when your lifestyle is a certain way,
we like it, that's why it's our lifestyle.
So we don't want to change.
So okay, some more stuff about,
well, also I thought I'd throw this out as far as cooking,
steaming is really good, you know,
and that doesn't take that long.
Some good frozen veggies, you know, put them in the steamer
and that's healthy and again, organic is good.
So okay, so if you have a microwave oven,
don't use it for your food, use it for your heating bed.
And I know I've read some stuff on the internet,
say it says get six feet away.
Well, the head is incorrect.
You need to be 20 feet away from that thing if you're using it.
And yeah, yeah, and out of the room, out of the room,
20 feet away, it blasts.
It is really strong.
So, and if you do use it for food, never ever, ever do plastic in.
So to sum up microwaves,
it's the strongest radiation device in your home.
I have entitled them super-powered radiation machines.
Maybe we should call some of these things
what they really are.
Yeah, they're not microwaves anymore.
The less they're all chips, you know.
Yes.
So, and then we have a little blog on our website.
And it's called your microwave is microwaving you.
And that's the truth.
Well, that is a pretty nasty first culprit.
Yes, it is.
Yeah, it is.
All right, culprit number two.
Yeah, it's gonna be wireless Wi-Fi routers.
So, again, this is using the RF radio frequency signals,
which is EMF, and it's, when it's connected to the internet.
And it's the same radiation that's coming out of cell phones,
smart meters, laptops, baby monitors, tablets and computers.
And just a word about baby monitors,
because that's a tough one too,
because mommy and daddy wanna hear baby
and make sure baby's okay,
but they are absolutely bad and dangerous
and sapping your baby.
Maybe not as strong as a microwave,
but they are strong also.
And it's not good.
And it's just crazy right now.
I mean, seriously, they're coming out with smart,
there is smart diapers.
Yes, smart car.
You know, and there's these mats that baby lays on.
And it kind of keeps track of their heartbeat and stuff.
Those are all emitting dangerous EMF radiation.
So, I mean, I didn't really wanna get into all that other stuff,
but I'm just throwing that out for people.
You can Google it, you can check it out.
It's for real, and we want your children to be protected.
Yeah, I think the biggest thing on the market right now
is the new outlet.
I think it's called, and it's marketed like a little owl.
And I think you put it on the baby's big toe
and it's a Bluetooth body monitor.
And so, it's constantly sending the frequency
through the body monitor exactly what you were saying,
heartbeat, breathing, all of that.
So, it's supposed to be able to track
or provide you with a warning of potential Sid
like behavior or precursors
when in reality, that could actually be contributing to Sid's.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, absolutely.
So, yeah, that's a bad deal.
I'm glad we brought that up.
So, okay, so let's see.
Some of the physical symptoms from Wi-Fi
that people may be experiencing is sleep issues.
It's a biggie.
Headaches, memory, brain fog,
even burning, tingling, and numbness, extreme tiredness.
And those are just like initial symptoms, but then it gets worse
because when you factor in the other like environmental toxins,
it increases it exponentially.
Okay, so if you put all the chemicals that we're getting
from the glyphosate and the water and the food and the air
and plus whatever else people are doing to themselves
spraying on their hairspray and I'll make up them
and spraying for bugs in their house and whatever.
And you add that with EMF, it is increasing.
It's not one plus one, it's one plus 20 or whatever.
And there was some research done that wireless
and other EMF radiation can act as a cold promoter
and meaning the effect of a known carcinogen
is intensified when the wireless is added into the mix.
It's like mixing drugs.
And so this is a really, really bad deal.
Wow.
Yeah.
And then even the who, the World Health Organization
which drags their feed and is way behind is not doing
what I think meant, well not just me,
I mean hundreds of scientists and thousands of studies
are saying we got to do more.
But they said four of their six cold carcinogenesis studies
showed increased cancer incidence after the exposure
of RF, EMF in combination with the known carcinogen.
So yeah.
So it acts synergistically with other toxic exposures
to promote cancer.
And I know you guys specialize in that, bless your hearts.
And but again, we prefer people not to get it.
So, you know, let's see.
Now there was another study and this one was without
the other carcinogens and they were confirming
an earlier experiment and they found that weak cell phone signals,
and that's the same as Wi-Fi signals.
Promoted the growth of lung tumors, liver tumors,
and lymphomas in mice.
So I think that we have another blog on our website,
tell it to the rats, you know.
So it gives rats cancer but not people, you know,
and okay, I don't know if I go for that one, right?
So, but any rate, yeah.
So again, we're explaining the dangers of these things.
Just because if you don't know it's dangerous,
you won't do anything.
And hopefully people are willing to change their lifestyles
to be healthy.
Right. Well, you're certainly going to have a,
it's going to be a rarity for a family
not to have Wi-Fi in the home because it seems like
everything is connected to that.
So what is something simple or some things that are simple
that people can do or be mindful of
that can make a difference in their home?
Yeah, and that's what we wanted to get to, too.
Not just to tell you this is dangerous, goodbye.
But give some options or tips to do.
Yes, because internet again is something
we all use all the time.
So, but you will, they will notice,
like when you're going to hook up your internet,
what's all those other names on there?
That's your neighbors and who knows who else?
And that shows just how strong these things are.
So, best thing to do is hardwire.
Hardwire to the internet with the ethernet cable
so you don't need Wi-Fi.
And again, you know, like I said,
we go and we do inspections on people's houses.
And they'll say, well, we're all good, we're hardwired.
And I say, okay, fine, let me test it out and sure enough,
their router or modem is still zappin' up.
Because even though they thought they had the Wi-Fi off,
they didn't.
And some of those things are very difficult
to get the Wi-Fi off.
Because they think everybody wants it all the time.
And so we are happily radiating you 24-7, so on.
Okay, so that's the best.
Then to move the router farther away
from where you spend most of your time.
That's kind of a no-brainer, but we bring it out.
And that's because one thing we teach people
when we go to their houses is called TDs,
which is I think a very good one to bring out now
because the Super Bowl is coming up.
TDs, like Touchdowns, can we remember it?
But it's T is time, D is distance, and S is shielding.
So the time distance and shielding are what we do
with some of these, you know, with the EMFs.
So the less time you spend in electromagnetic field,
the less you're getting radiated, obviously.
And the more distance you can get,
then the signal's stronger and the radiation is weaker.
So that's why we say move away.
But you know, don't just put it right next to you
on your desk and sit there all day, you know,
with its app in you.
Okay, then also turn off the router when not in use.
If possible, and I don't know,
I've looked at some of the newer ones
that you don't want to do this.
But some of them may be the older,
if you have a little older router,
you may be able to do this, if you can figure out how to do it.
But you can go to your router settings up in your address
and your internet and look into there.
And sometimes you can turn down your power,
which is really cool.
Then also, like I said,
we're probably not going to throw that router out the door
is get a router guard, a shield, cage, or sock.
There's all sorts of things.
And you put those over it
and then that decreases the signal loss.
I do know that, and I'm not,
I won't be able to remember the pattern that I used,
but I know that when I received my most recent router,
it had actually two different Wi-Fi frequencies.
It had a 5G and I believe a 2G.
And so I had to Google how to remove the 5G component
through my internet provider
and a walk me through a series of steps.
And I actually ended up calling the company
and working with one of their providers
or assistants managers to walk me through the steps
to remove the 5G component.
And I know we'll talk about 5G at a different time,
but what people might not even realize
is you have multiple types of Wi-Fi frequencies
coming through your router to not just one.
Yes, and usually, so when you're,
like I said, there's those different names
when you're hooking up to internet.
So it'll probably show like the 5G hookup
and then there'll be two on there showing up for your house.
Like you said, get rid of that 5-1
because that's a double.
It's a double amp, it's a double amp.
And then this is a very, maybe the most important thing
is turn that thing off at night, turn it off at night.
So when you're sleeping, your body is not getting hit by that.
Yeah.
Have you done any research into covers
that go over or around a router?
Yeah.
You have?
OK.
And have you noticed any differences
if people put some kind of a protective cover
around their router?
Does that help?
Oh, absolutely.
OK.
They absolutely, those work.
So again, we are inspectors and consultants.
And so when we do consulting or we're doing an especially,
people ask us questions, whatever they want.
And we recommend what we know works.
So now this is another kind of side cut.
But I'm afraid there's lots of scams out there.
And I'm not trying to be mean, but it's true.
And so we test stuff.
And if it works, I can test it scientifically.
If I cannot test it scientifically,
I'm not necessarily going to say it doesn't work,
but I can't prove it.
So I'm not really recommending it like that.
But no, these covers that you can get do work.
So they don't totally cut the signal,
because then you wouldn't get your Wi-Fi.
Right.
But they'll knock it down like 90%, which is really good.
Yeah, that's great.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So.
Well, culprit number two.
Three.
That was number two, right?
Yeah, number two.
Is that number two?
Yep, yep, yep.
So we have number three now.
OK, yep, we're going to number three.
Sorry, I was closing out culprit number two.
I was closing.
Now we're entering.
It's a culprit number three.
So good.
We're going to do it again.
OK.
So now the third one is cordless phones.
Good thing about cordless phones is less people are having them.
But still, many people do.
And we go into homes, and they're totally oblivious again.
At one point, well, OK, I'll go a little more into it.
Can we solve the problem of cell phone radiation
by using a landline phone?
Answer is yes.
Unless it's a cordless phone.
Because studies show that cordless or wireless telephones
emit radiation just the same as cell phones.
Except for one thing.
They emit health-damaging EMFs constantly,
even when not being used.
And in many homes, I've tested these cordless phone radiation
and it's even more, much more powerful than a cell phone.
And it's constantly zoom zapping out into the home.
A little history in 1983, cordless phones
went mainstream selling out in phone centers
and millions were purchased.
And so sales are down now, of course, cell phones.
But many homes still used them.
And it's also interesting that both the handset
and the base of the phone send out pulse microwave radiation
non-stop.
They send signals back and forth because they're
in contact with each other, the base and the handset.
And that means, depending where you are standing,
when you're talking on it, the transmissions
go right through your brain to the base station.
Wow.
Yeah.
I mean, it makes sense when you explain it like that.
It makes perfect sense.
Yeah.
So unfortunately, government agencies plus the companies
that sell these devices assure us that this radiation is,
they don't necessarily for sure harmless,
but probably harmless, harmless.
And however, there is tons of studies and evidence
to show this is not the case.
And so what I look at and what everyone should look at,
when they go again and on the Google and looking at EMFs
and so on, is independent peer-reviewed research,
not paid off research by the big companies or whatever.
But independent peer-reviewed research, people who do not
have that financial stake within it, they just care
and are trying to find the truth.
So anyway, research from Swedish scientists
found that cordless telephones raised
your risk of developing cancer.
They studied patients with malignant brain tumors
and found the cancer risk was multiply
for those who use cordless phones.
And Dr. Magda Harvest, a PhD, and I really like her.
Anybody wants to Google her and look at her stuff?
Is a top expert on the adverse health effects of cordless phones?
And she says they should be banned, totally banned.
And she states there was conclusive evidence
that harms your heart, your brain, your children,
it affects brainwaves, memory, and sleep.
And yet how many people have a cordless phone
right next to their bed?
Could you spell her name?
Yeah, it's M-A-G-D-A.
And her last name is H-A-V-A-S.
Great, thank you.
Then people can say that.
And I believe she has their own website
and lots of information there, too.
So what the statistics are right now.
40% of US households still have a landline.
And no doubt many of them are cordless.
So that is kind of the background on the history
and also the danger of cordless phones.
Or cordless phones, I mean, cordless phones.
I do know that there is a movement
to kind of bring back some of the what they're
calling retro corded phones into the home.
So for the few people that do have landlines,
I do know that there's kind of a trend with that
because then it's something vintage.
But I know that it's not always easy to find.
You really have to dig for those because so many
were thrown away when everybody was bringing a cordless phone
into their homes.
Right, right, right.
And that is the solution.
That is the solution.
If you want to have a landline, get a corded one.
Get corded one.
And there you go, it's not emitting radiation.
So that's the thing.
So what we recommend then, really, we never recommend
when we go to housing, we say just get rid of it
and get a corded with a long cord.
I can't have a very long cord.
So walk around, you know, get a 50 foot cord.
You get everybody in the house all tangled up in it
or get under a chair or something.
However, we do have suggestions for those who just have
to have them.
They want one.
So keep the base as far away from you.
The base is as far away from you as possible.
There's the distance factor again.
Keep the hands set away from you as they're
trying to connect all the time to the base.
Unplug it when you're not using it.
Definitely unplug it at night, just like the Wi-Fi router.
Never keep it in your bedroom.
Use the speaker phone so it's not by your head.
Keep your conversation short.
And they do have, although again, I think you have to really
search to try and find one.
They do have low EMF cordless phones.
And then also keep one corded phone plugged in
to your attachments, you know.
And so that if you disconnect the cordless one,
you still can talk, still get your calls and still call.
That's great.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
One more thing on the cordless phones.
And we do do the inspections in businesses too.
And I think that's an important thing.
You know, again, there's a lot of denial.
We do schools too.
But there's a lot of denial because, well, for one thing,
the businesses, the schools, the factories that, you know,
they don't want to admit they're hurting their employees.
But they are.
And so even though home phones are becoming less common
as people are using their cell phones more, the offices
in our country and around the world,
they are still using those cordless phones and wireless headsets.
So these things are tremendous health risks for the people.
If you think about it, it's sending signals through their body
and through their brains eight hours a day.
And it's extremely dangerous.
So again, what do you do when you're working for somebody?
But if you could share some information with them, switch
to a corded again, corded headset, air tube is best,
and or just keep the wireless producing products
as far away from your body and head as possible
for those who are working in those environments.
Those are excellent suggestions.
Well, that's, I would say that that's a great start
if families can just begin to address those few small things.
I mean, a journey of 1,000 miles begins with a single step.
And as we were saying earlier, that this rabbit hole
of EMF goes very deep.
And it can be incredibly overwhelming.
And so for families that are just
trying to get started with doing the best
that they can, these three primary culprits,
if they can do something to lower the amount of EMFs
that are emitted in their home, that those three components
in and of itself can make a huge difference
in a family's life and in their health.
And then beyond that, there are resources available
for them to bring in an expert or learn more information
on other things that they can do to continue to suss out
what's in their home that's giving off all of these EMFs.
Yes.
And that really is the goal.
Because, you know, like, well, go live on a desert island,
but there's probably a cell phone antenna there.
So it's to reduce as much as we can.
All the toxins coming from all those different things.
So, but I was going to share some an encouraging word here
if it's okay.
And I'm a Christian.
And this is from the Bible, but it's about a story with Jesus.
And there was a man with leprosy that came to him one day.
And so leprosy back then was an incurable disease.
And there are incurable diseases today for people.
And he said to statement, he says,
Lord, if you are willing, you can heal me and make me clean.
And it's so cool to me how Jesus reacted to that.
Because people, you know, they wonder sometimes,
well, maybe God wants me sick
or maybe he doesn't care or maybe he's not seeing me.
Or maybe he's just, you know,
often somewhere in outer space and doing something else.
But Jesus reached out and touched the man.
And he said, I want to.
I'm willing to be healed.
And it says instantly, the leprosy disappeared.
So that's the best case scenario, right?
Pray and instantly be healed.
But if we're not, then praise the Lord, this kind of clinic
and this, you know, you know,
I'm up his back being in these different things to help.
But I just wanted to encourage in the sense
that Jesus loves us and he cares about us.
He is a healer and he wants to help us.
So I want to make sure that.
No, thank you so much, Jim.
Could you give our listeners and our viewers a quick information,
a quick little bit of information on just your company,
how people can get in touch with you.
If they would like to reach out to you and LaRae
to work with them on additional ways
to help protect their home from EMFs.
Yes.
And of course, we do want to help as many people as we can.
Our website is emfinspecting.com.
Our phone number is 651-230-942-9.
And you can email us at info at EMF-inspecting,
help at EMF-inspecting, safety at EMF-inspecting.
But I think info is the main one we're getting now.
But any rate, yeah, we love to help people.
It's our passion, really.
It's not just a business.
We believe God has led us into it
and people are very grateful and thankful.
They say there's not many people who do what you do.
And so yeah, but we love it.
And we want to help.
Wonderful.
Well, thank you so much, Jim, for being on this interview with me
and please give my regards to your wife.
Well, thank you, Michelle.
And it was a delight to be with you today.
And we just pray many people will be encouraged and help.
Certainly.
We will be talking to you soon.
OK.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye now.